- Wait, do you believe in
ghosts or do you believe in
them?
- Yeah, but I don't believe
in like, malevolent, like ghost stories.
I believe like, you know,
our better angels are there.
- Okay.
- And they're with us and
- they take care of us.
- Oh, you don't believe in
yeah, mean ghosts,
you believe in-
- No, no, no,
mean scary ghosts,
I feel like we could
talk to and sort of like
you know, negotiate with,
- (laughs)
- you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah. I get that.
I get that.
- Yeah.
Don't watch me
while I shower and I'll stay outta
your, your space.
- (laughs)
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Or watch me while I
shower, you're welcome.
(audience laughing)
Yeah. Yeah. You're welcome
- Depends on the mood.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, I suppose.
- I can't see you watching me,
so whatever! (laughs)
It's like, so tell, I just invite, invited
every creeper to my house,
- I know, I was like-
(audience laughing)
- like, subtly, and I
didn't mean to do that.
So wait, tell, I can't
- I was like I can't engage
with this conversation anymore
- You're like,
I'm actually out.
- Where's my parachute?
(guests laughing)
- Tell us about "Ghosts" though!
By the way, my musical director
is obsessed with your show.
- Oh cool!
- Yes. I just needed to tell you that.
- Thank you, thanks a lot.
(audience clapping)
- Yes, he's obsessed.
He was like, I love this show.
I love this show.
I was like, I'm gonna tell him.
- We just, we got super lucky.
Our cast is great.
And our creators, it's about a
a couple, Rose McIver
and myself, Sam, and Jay,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and we move into this
mansion in upstate New York.
And it's haunted by a variety
of ghosts who I can't see, but Rose can.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we sort of uh,
then hilarity ensues.
It's a family comedy about the undead.
Oh, and those two guys.
Look at that!
- (laughs)
- You guys are like top notch production.
- We, I'm telling you super professional,
season three. Season three.
- Guitars on the wall,
This is the real deal.
- I can't play them
well, but they're there.